اهلا بكم اتحدث هذا الاسبوع الى جيمس
توبنز الرئيس المتميز في الدبلوماسيه
والامن في مؤسسه ايران والذي شغل مناصب
رفيعه جدا في وزاره الخارجيه والبيت
الابيض بما في ذلك مساعد وزير الخارجيه
لاوروبا والمساعد الخاص للرئيس الامريكي
جورج بوش في نصف الكره الغربي
والمستشار الخاص له ومساعد وزير الخارجيه
لمنطقه البلقان وسفير الامريكي لدى
المجموعه الاوروبيه وبعد ان عمل معي
الرئيسين جورج دبليو بوشوا
الممثل الخاص للرئيس باراك اوباما في
افغانستان وباكستان ساناقش معه الحرب في
اوكرانيا وعلاقتها بمستقبل اوروبا ومنطقه
البلقان فضلا عن مستقبل افغانستان والشرق
الاوسط والذي جاء على ذكرها كلها في كتابه
الخدمه الخارجيه خمسه عقود على الخطوط
الاماميه
للدبلوماسيه الامريكيه من العربيه احييكم
اينما كنتم انا منتهى الرمحي وهذا البعد
الاخر
[موسيقى]
احييكم من جديد هل يمكن ان تقف اوروبا خلف
الولايات المتحده في الصراع بينها وبين
الصين على ما يبدو في الحد الادنى فان
القاره العجوز اصبحت مياله اكثر لتصديق
سفارات الانذار الامريكيه كما يتضح من
الاجتماع في البيت الابيض بين اورسولا
فوندرلاين رئيسه المفوضيه الاوروبيه
الرئيس الامريكي في نهايه اجتماعهم تعهد
جو بايدن واوسلاف بالفعل ببدء المفاوضات
بشان المواد الخام الاستراتيجيه بالنسبه
للباقي خصص البيان الصحفي الصادر عن
الاجتماع التركيز على الاتفاق على تعزيز
التعاون بين الولايات المتحده والاتحاد
الاوروبي منع تسرب التكنولوجيا الحساسه
الى الوجهات التي تدير استراتيجيات
الاندماج المدني
والعسكري في اشاره الى الصين معددا ضوابط
التصدير والاستثمارات من اجل التكيف مع
بيئه
جيوستراتيجيه جديده كانت تلك كلمات حلوه
في اذان الولايات المتحده التي ارادت
لسنوات باسم الامن اقناع اوروبا باتخاذ
اجراءات تجاريه تقليديه ضد بكين ورغم ان
مسؤولا اوروبيا كبيرا اتهم فوندرلاين
بتجاوز تفويضها بعدم استشاره السبعه
والعشرين مسبقا فمن الواضح ان انتخاب
بايدن والحرب في اوكرانيا ادت الى تقريب
الاوروبيين من الولايات المتحده على الرغم
من انهم دفعوا ثمنا باهظا مقابل ذلك مع
ذلك ما زالت هناك تحفظات ففي الوقت الذي
تؤيد فرنسا هامش حركه اكبر فان دول اخرى
مثل بولندا او دول البلطيق مستعده بلا
شروط للوقوف الى جانب الولايات المتحده ضد
بكين اما المانيا فممزقه بين ولائها
الامريكيين وصناعاتها القويه التي تحتاج
الى السوق الصينيه اهلا بك معنا سعاده
السفير ولك خبره طويله في كل من الخارجيه
الامريكيه او البيت الابيض وفي عده دول
وكنت سفير للولايات المتحده لدى المجموعه
الاوروبيه وعند الدول ايضا في البلقان
واسيا وهذه الحقيقه فرصه لنا في البعد
الاخر للتعرف على رايك في عده قضايا دعنا
نبدا اولا من ملف الساعه وهو ملف اوروبا
كيف ترى وضعها حاليا
اعتقد بان اوروبا
كلها تقف ضد سلوكيات الروسيه
فهنالك وحده كبيره بين الدول الاوروبيه
واستراتيجياتها يبدو انها ناجحه في وجه
روسيا
والكل كما نرى يقدم التضحيات
او اكثرهم واقصد بشكل خاص الاوكرانيين
لهما الاحتمار لكل
التضحيات ونحن نتعاطف معهم وكذلك ندعم
اللاجئين الاوكرانيين الذين سيحصلون على
معامله جيده جدا هل هذا الموقف الواحد
لاوروبا هو برايك من جعل الحرب الروسيه
على اوكرانيا تستمر حتى الان لانه في ملف
الحرب هذه كنا نعتقد حقيقه انها ربما
تستمر اسابيع او شهور الان دخلنا العام
الثاني كل المؤشرات تتزايد على كون هذه
الحرب مستمره هل توافقنا على ذلك
نعم وللاسف
نامل ان
وقف اطلاق النار سيتحقق ونعود الى طائرات
المفاوضات ولكن في الحقيقه لا احد يستطيع
ان يحدد متى سيحصل ذلك او كيف فلا شيء في
الافق يشير الى ذلك ويبدو ان هذه الحرب
ستدوم لفتره طويله ويكون انت
اغلب الاشخاص ما كانوا يصدقوا ان اي حرب
ستندل ان الحرب بهذا الشكل غير ومنطقيه
على الاطلاق
هنالك الشخصيه واحده هي التي تسببت بكل ما
جرى
وبات جليا ان حساباته
كلها كانت غير دقيقه ولا احد ليعرفهم
الحسابات التي تقادته الى هذه المهمه
الانتحاريه والتي يحاول من خلالها احتلال
اوكرانيا بالقوه
ولكن
هذا اصبح خلفنا الان التداعيات تداعيات
هذه الحرب العالم كله يعاني منها المشهد
الحالي بعد مرور اكثر من عام على الحرب
يشير الى ان كتله جديده بدات بالظهور في
مواجهه الولايات المتحده عندك روسيا
والصين من ناحيه ومن الناحيه الاخرى
الولايات المتحده ولاننا نتحدث عن اوروبا
الا ترى في هذا تراجع استراتيجي لموقع
الاتحاد الاوروبي
لا اظن ذلك
الاتحاد الاوروبي ولاله المتحده لطالما
وقفوا جنب الاجنب في المسائل التي الاهميه
خاصه فيما يخص السلام وهذا ما يفعلونه
الان ولا من اي تراجعا لدوري الاتحاد
الاوروبي فهم يلعبون دورا اساسيا خاصه
فيما يخص تقديم الدعم الاقتصادي والولايات
المتحده تلعب دور القيادي في تزويد
اوكرانيا بالدعم العسكري ولكن كل هذا
يتزامن معا
التوزيعي الادوار بين اوروبا وامريكا على
مدى السنوات الطويله الماضيه وانا في
الحقيقه راضي جدا في ما يخص الدوره
الاوروبي
وضع في اوروبا لا ادري ان كانت اوروبا
بصمه ام لا يعني اضافه للحرب في اوكرانيا
هناك ايضا ملف بدا يعود من جديد للساحه
الاوروبيه يتعلق بالبلقان وانت كنت سفير
هناك كيف ترى الوضع في البلقان هل هو مرشح
للتدهور اكثر خاصه في البوسنه
يبدو ان هنالك انجاز ايجابي تحقق هناك
الصرب وكوسفور لا تعترفان بعضهما البعض
ولكنهم يستمرون بمحاوله
رفع الشرعيه عن الطرف الاخر ومنذ الاقتراح
الالماني
[موسيقى]
القائمه على سياسه
الجمهوريه الاتحاديه كما حصل المانيا
الغربيه لم تعترف بالمانيا الشرقيه او
لكنهم لم يمنعوا الاشخاص من التعامل معهم
وهم انفسهم ايضا
خلقوا قناه دبلوماسيه
لما سموها العلاقات الالمانيه الداخليه
وحققه تقدما كبيرا على مدى السنوات في
تطبيع الاوضاع هناك من دون الاعتراف
بشرعيه الطرف الاخر
ولذلك يبدو
ان قصبهم
والصرب يعملون على شيء من هذا القبيل
المسيحه خطوه كبيره الى الامانه خاصه بعد
الانضمام مثلا الامم المتحده
كما اعتقد بان السلوكيات الروسيه وحقيقه
ان روسيا يبدو انها تخسر المعركه سيضعف
موقفها في دول البلقان
هل تعتقد بانه اتفاق دايتون متعلق
بالبوسنا ما زال صالح البعض يرى بانه على
ابواب الانهيار
[موسيقى]
نعم هذا ما يقولونه منذ
ان تم توقيعها عليه قبل 25 عاما
ولكنني لا اعتقد بانها على وشك الانهيار
كما اعتقد بان الاوروبيين
سوف
يضغطون بشكل خاص
[موسيقى]
على مثلا
الانضمامي الصربي الى اتحاد الاوروبي
لضمان عدم انهيار الاتفاق
صربيا وحدها انما العديد من الدول في
اوروبا الشرقيه الان تسعى للانضمام
للاتحاد الاوروبي على راسها اوكرانيا في
هذه المشاريع هل ستكون في صالح الاتحاد
الاوروبي ام انها ستضعف الاتحاد الاوروبي
بحيث يكون الاتحاد الاوروبي
مجبر على على الدخول في حرب حقيقيه في حال
تعرض اي منها لاي عدوان
لست متاكدا
ولكن لا اعتقد بان هذا سيضعف هو الاتحاد
الاوروبي
[موسيقى]
كما سمعنا اوكرانيا هي الدوله اكثر قوه
ومتحده ما توقعها الكثيرون كما انها اكثر
كفاءه على الصعيد العسكري
او لا شك بانها ستعتبر من الاصول المفيده
للاتحاد الاوروبي
ولكننا لا نعرف الى اين تتجه الامور او
كيف ستنتهي من الممكن ان
ينتصر الطرف على الاخر
ويحققون اصلا حاسما ولكن على الارجاح بان
الحرب ستنتهي
باتفاق غير مورد
يتركوا على السياده غير محدده في مناطق
معينه
ويتركوه كل طرف يسيطر على اراضي يطالب بها
الطرف الاخر لذلك سيكون تحديا صعبا على
مدى سنوات القادمه
ولكن يبدو ان هنالك
مصاحف مصالح كثيره في اعاده بناء اوكرانيا
وستكون هنالك حزمه كريمه جدا
لاعاده بناء اوكرانيا بعد ان تنتهي الحرب
حتى وان انتهت باتفاق مؤقت اوقف اطلاق
النار وليس عبر التسويه
وهذا سيمنحه الاوروبيين
الشيء اضافي لتوحيدهم يعملوا عليه معا وهو
اعاده بناء اوكرانيا طيب على الجانب الاخر
هل تعتقد او كيف تقيم لزياره التي قامت
بها رئيسه المفوضيه الاوروبيه الى واشنطن
ولقائها بالرئيس جو بايدن هل قربت الاتحاد
الاوروبي اكثر للاستفاف وراء واشنطن في
الصراع مع الصين
لا اعرف ان كانت الصين هي محور هذه
المحادثات
او ان كانت ضمن
الاولويات
اغلب السياسات
كانت ملصقه في اوكرانيا ولكن اوروبا
التنظي في نفس اتجاه الولايات المتحده وهو
عدم مواجهه الصين ولكن مع الادراك بان
الصين لديها سلوكيات او بعض سلوكيات غير
المقبوله
وبالتالي هم في منافسه تتطلب منا
الاستجابه
وهنالك حركه كبيره على الاقل من الجانب
الاوروبي ولو فقط عبر الخطاب او الكلام
ولكن
اعتقد
بان هنالك اتجاه موحد على الاقل عبر
الاطلسي بس يعني انت ذكرت بانه ما كانت
الصين اولويه لكن تم نقاش مساله
التكنولوجيا والاتفاقيه تحدثت عن نقل
التكنولوجيا بحيث تشكل درعا امام الصين
او درعا امام تكنولوجيا الصينيه اذا الصين
كانت في صلب الاحداث او في صلب النقاش
[موسيقى]
ومشاهدينا الكرام اهلا بكم معنا من جديد
ومره اخرى اذهب الى ضيف ساعات السفير جيمس
واسال عن كنا نتحدث قبل الفاصل عن الصين
الان باختصار الى اين يمكن ان تتجه
الاوضاع مع الصين على مستوى الاوروبي وعلى
مستوى الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
اعتقد بان الاجابه عن هذا السؤال صعب جدا
فليس واضحا
الى اين يتجه رئيس شيا فيما يخص
دفعه
صعود الصين او الى ماذا اي مدى يرغب
بالوصول اليه
فقد
تنعى عن سياساتي اسلافه
والتي تمثلت بتجنب النزاعات والتركيز على
النمو الاقتصادي وهذا الرئيس الصيني يقصد
شي لا يتجنب النزاعات والمواجهات على
الاقل الكلاميه
وكما نسب النمو قد تضاعفت
ويواجه اوضاعا حيث الشعبيته بدات
بالانخفاض وبشكل سريع
واقتصاده لن ينمو بنفس السرعه التي نرى
عليها خلال 20 عاما الماضيه
والسلوك سلوكياته في نفس الوقت سلوكيات
الصين بشكل عام توحد الدول ضده
فهل سيستمر في هذا الطريق ام
[موسيقى]
حل السياره اي مصلحه في
الضغطي مثلا على اعاده توحيدي تايوان او
ضمه تايوان ام هل سيعودون الى سياساتي
الرؤساء السابقين للصين الذين مثلوا
تحديات اقل العالم وهذا ما ادار بفائده
كبيره للصين على الاقل فيه وعلى الصعيد
الاقتصادي لا اعرف الاجابه عن هذه الاسئله
ولكن اعرفه بان سياسته
موجهه تجاه التشجيع على ذلك
وبالتاكيد هنالك ايضا مستوى من او البعض
قلقون اكثر مني فيما يخص الصين
يعني على المستوى الاقتصادي لا يوجد حتى
الان ما يشير الى انه الاقتصاد الصيني
سيتراجع قريبا وهنا نتساءل دائما عن رؤيه
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه والاتحاد
الاوروبي لهذه المساله المهمه جدا عن صيد
العالم وهي الاقتصاد اسمح لي ان اخصص جزء
من هذا الحوار لعلاقتك بافغانستان انت كنت
سفير هناك وكنت المابوت الخاص لرئيس جورج
بوش للتنسيق مع المعارضه الافغانيه بعد
هجوم سبتمبر 2001 الارهابي كيف تقيم عملك
الان بعد مرور اثنين وعشرين عاما على ذلك
لا نستطيع تجنب الاستنتاج من ان
الجهود حققت فشل ان في النهايه
حققت
ازدهارة لافغانستان في البدايه
وهناك ضعف الاشخاص الذي يستطيعون القراءه
في افغانستان اليوم مقارنه ب 2001
واغلب الافغانيين لديهم كانت الوصول الى
الانترنت وحتى لديهما هواتفان قال لم بكل
لديهم اي هواتف في عام 2001 كما ان معدلات
الاعمار ايضا ارتفعت بشكل كبير جدا
وافغانستان حققت تقدما اكثر في على العقد
الاول بعد عام 2001 او اكثر من اي دوله
اخرى اما الان فهي
تقاسؤول بقاعده بطيئه جدا ولا تزال بين
افقر الدول في العالم
ولكن حصره تغيير كبير جدا في ظروف الشعب
الافغاني والان
عادوا الى حيثما كانوا قبل عشرين عاما من
الان وهذا مخيب للاعمال اعتقد بان
الولايات المتحده اخطات في حساباتها
عندما اعتقد ان هذه الشراكه قد تكون
مستدامه وان افغانستان ستكون قادره
على
الاعتماد على نفسها وعدم الاعتماد على
المساعدات الغربيه
يعني تتحمل الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
الجزء الاكبر من هذه الكارثه الانسانيه
التي تعاني منها افغانستان الان
نحن بالتاكيد نتحمل مسؤوليه ولكن
المسؤوليه الاساسيه تقع على عاتقه
الطالبان هم الذين استولوا على الحكم وليس
نحن
ولكن نعم نستطيع ان نقول بان الولايات
المتحده مسؤوله عن تصرفاتها
ونستطيع ان
ننتقد او نحكم على سياسات الولايات
المتحده حسب النتائج والنتائج مخيبه
يعني هذا النقاش ممكن يكون صعب لانه في
اتفاقيات وقعت بين الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه وحركه طالبان في جهود تابعناها
في الدوحه لسنوات طويله لتوقيع الاتفاق
وانسحبت الولايات المتحده الامريكيه من
افغانستان لصالح طالبان بنهايه الامر يعني
وكان افغانستان سلمت تسليما لحركه طالبان
لذلك نتساءل عن المسؤوليه الامريكيه هنا
هذا صحيح
او هذا الامر غير طبيعي على الاطلاق
اداره
وقرارها لتفاوض مع طالبان من دون مشاركه
الحكومه الافغانيه
كانت
مفاجئه جدا وغير متوقعه
والقرار ايضا كان غير متوازن والاتفاق
الذي تم التوصل اليه عهده كان بمثابه
وثيقه استسلام والرئيس بايدن بخلاف مشورته
كافه قاده الجيش والاجهزه الاستخباراتيه
وحتى المستشار الدبلوماسيين قرر تطبيق هذا
القرار او الاتفاق
لا نستطيع ان ندافع عن هذا القرار واي
رئيس اخر ربما ما كان سيفعل ذلك
المجال برايك لدى المجتمع الدولي اي دور
في افغانستان يمكنه القيام به لانقاذ
البلاد مع تراجع وضع المراه مع تراجع
عمليه التعليم للمراه مع هذه الظروف
الاقتصاديه وحاله الفقر الصعبه هناك
اعتقد بان المجتمع له اثر محدود وامكانات
محدوده ولكن يجب على مجتمع الدولي السعي
وراءه اي فرصه
وكل الاجواء غير مشجعه وكذلك عدم
الاستسلام في خضم كل ما يجري
المصدر الوحيد
للمساعدات الاجنبيه
لمكافحه المجاعه وهذا امر مهم جدا
ومن المخيب
للاعمال ان تكون كل هذه المساعدات
الانسانيه محدوده جدا
وقرار الطالباني فيما يخص المراه ايضا
مخيب جدا
لانهم وعدوا باشياء مختلفه وكان يبدو انهم
سيسمحون للفتيات بالذهاب الى المدارس
هو حتى ما بعد المدارس
الابتدائيه والثانويه ولكن القياده
الدينيه اتخذت قرارا مختلفا
والقياده الدينيه او غير الدينيه في هذا
الحاله اتخذت كما قلت هذا القرار
ولم تكن له اي شعبيه في افغانستان واضح
واضح اصلا دخلت الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه لافغانستان للتخلص من هذه
القياده الدينيه للمعاقبتها على الاحداث
الارهابيه ب 2001 ولكنها لم تكن الحاله
الوحيده لخروج الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
راينا خروجها من افغانستان وراينا خروجها
من الشرق الاوسط راينا خروجها من العراق
بهذه الطريقه بعد ان تقريبا سلمت العراق
لايران الا ترى ان ذلك بعث الرساله
الخاطئه للعالم الا ترى انه هذا احد اسباب
المشهد الحالي اللي بنعيشه
الولايات المتحده لم تغادر العراق او ولا
تزال تحقق وتوازن هاما في وجه النفوذ
الايراني
وهي هناك تدرب الجيش العراقي
وحققت بعض النجاح
من المفاجئ
ان العراق وضعه افضل من وضعه افغانستان
اذا ما اخذنا الاعتبار ان التدخل في
العراق واجه صعوبات اكبر بكثير من
الصعوبات التي تواجهنا في افغانستان وفي
الحقيقه
اعتقد بان قرار غزو العراق في عام 2003
كان اكبر عائقا التي واجه تحقيق النجاح في
افغانستان اللي انا حول الانتباه هو
الموارد الاميركيه
الى اتجاه اخر فلا اعتقد بان امريكا
انسحبت من العراق ولم تنسحب ايضا من الشرق
الاوسط العراق خرج من حرب
ونستطيع الان
مثلا بضروره الحرب الحرب لم تكن ضروريه
على الاطلاق وربما غزونا البلاد عن طريق
الخطا وهذا ما سيذكره التاريخ
نغز
الدوله ونكتشف بعد اسابيع بين هذا الغزو
كان غير ضرووريا
لانه لم تكن هنالك اي اسلحه دمار شامل ولا
حتى ارهابيين
بعد ذلك كانت هنالك سلوكيات متهوره
فلذلك اعتقد بان العراق
هو مثال عن
الاصرار والعزيمه في وجه الخصوم
ومن المدهش
كم حققت امريكا بعد كل هذه البدايه السيئه
مستشار البيت الابيض والسفير الامريكي
البارز الاسبق جيمس توبنز شكرا جزيلا لك
لمشاركتك معنا هذه الحلقه من البعد الاخر
الف شكر والى هنا مشاهدينا الكرام تنتهي
حلقه اليوم من برنامج البعد الاخر يمكنكم
دائما متابعتنا على مواقع التواصل
الاجتماعي تويتر فيسبوك ويوتيوب كما
يمكنكم الاستماع على حلقتنا على العربيه
بودكاست ويمكنكم مشاهدتها على منصه شاهد
الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]